We have a Republican governor here in Massachusetts,
I've mentioned him before.
His name is Charlie Baker, and he just signed
into law a bill giving every resident of Massachusetts
the option to vote by mail in the fall and
in the primaries leading up to the fall, if
indeed that is what we want to do now.
I have not hidden this from folks since the
start of the coronavirus pandemic.
I did not vote for Charlie Baker.
I'm not a Republican, but he has been a Republican
who has done a good job.
Big picture on the Corona virus.
And he's doing a lot of the right thing.
So if I wanted to criticize, certainly he
could have started stay at home a little earlier.
He could have talked about the importance
of wearing masks earlier.
But Massachusetts is one of the few states
that has actually gotten the virus, what we
would call under control.
As of right now, and this may change as cases
continue to explode in many states.
My belief is that at some point, because you
can't block travel between states, or at least
it doesn't appear as though you can because
of the Constitution, we are going to have
a bleed over effect.
I am fully expecting that as we get into late
summer and early fall, Massachusetts will
start to see more cases.
But as of right now, we've seen dramatic declines
in cases and much of it has been under or
related to Republican Governor Charlie Baker's
leadership.
And likewise, we now have a statewide vote
by mail, which is extremely important and
completely and obviously logical given the
corona virus pandemic.
The secretary of state Web site now says,
quote, In July, meaning yesterday a new law
was passed to allow registered voters in Massachusetts
to vote by mail in any 20-20 election with
no excuse needed as required by the new law.
A vote by mail application will be mailed
to every person who is registered to vote
by July one and who had not already requested
an absentee ballot for the state primary or
for all elections this year.
A second mailing will be sent out in September
to all voters who have not already applied
for vote by mail for the November election.
The applications are pre addressed to your
local election official and no postage is
necessary.
So they're not just sending ballots around.
The fear mongering from the Trumpy and right
is you just start sending ballots places.
Anybody could fill them in and return them
and voter fraud and to let a little know all
that stuff.
The reality is what they're doing is they're
taking the list of registered voters and sending
them applications for absentee ballots, which
you still must return.
They must be delivered to the local election
office no later than four business days before
the election.
This is the right move.
This is simple.
Just do it.
Come on, states.
It's the right thing to do.
It's the safe thing to do.
And the problem is great.
Massachusetts is doing it.
Biden's going to win Massachusetts easily.
In other words, what I mean is the states
that will be close where people may be scared
to vote in person because of the pandemic.
Those are the states where you might actually
see a different outcome if there isn't vote
by mail.
And many of those are the states that are
not interested in doing vote by mail.
Now, fortunately, there are important states
that have done it.
I believe Pennsylvania and Ohio, Arizona,
Texas has temporarily said fear of catching
the virus counts as a valid reason to vote
absentee mitt.
Maybe Iowa, but this needs to be something
every state does.
And and in fact, when we look at Trump careening
down hill in the polls and we look at everything
that's going on, his reelection depends on.
Yes.
Lying about the state of the economy, lying
about the state of the pandemic.
But it also depends on suppressing the vote.
And not allowing vote by mail is something
that could, in very material terms, dissuade
people from voting at all.
Back to Charlie Baker in Massachusetts.
Just just a little bit, because I anticipate
some of the emails I might receive.
I have no delusions that Charlie Baker is
the height of progressivism.
He's a former health insurance CEO.
He's like a Mitt Romney type Republican, essentially.
But it shouldn't be unusual that you have
a governor who listens to doctors in science.
In other words, what's notable about the fact
that Charlie Baker, a Republican governor,
has mostly handled the virus correctly is
that it is unusual to have a Republican governor
who says, I'm going to do what the doctors
recommend.
We have a pandemic.
I'm going to make decisions based on science
and the medical community.
I'm going to close things.
I'm going to allow vote by mail for everybody.
The reason that this is newsworthy, the reason
that I'm talking in these terms of we have
a Republican governor who has actually managed
this pretty well, is that it's so rare when
you look at governors like Ron DeSantis in
Florida.
I mean, just off the deep end, Greg.
Abbott in Texas, and in particular, it actually.
Abbott has come back to reality a little bit
saying we need masks.
We should probably slow down or stop on bars.
The lieutenant governor there, Dan Patrick,
has been particularly crazy.
You've got Doug Deucy in Arizona and many,
many others.
That is why it is so notable that a Republican
governor like Charlie Baker has done the right
thing.
Now, I have some criticisms of what Charlie
Baker is doing.
I believe it is too early to do.
Indoor dining phase three in Massachusetts
includes casinos and movie theaters.
I just disagree.
I'm not going to any of those.
I've decided I'm comfortable with outdoor
dining right now.
I'm not going inside.
I mean, it's just it's not necessary.
It's summer.
There are articles that are linking card present
restaurant receipts, receipts to increased
case numbers.
So it does seem like the indoor dining is
a problem.
I think it's an unnecessary risk right now,
particularly when we don't listen.
There may not even be a gap between wave one
and two, but we're anticipating more cases
in the fall.
So I disagree with Baker on that.
I think it's too early.
Big picture managing it well.
Vote by mail for everybody in Massachusetts.
Absolutely.
The right decision.
I'm glad to see it.
We now just need states where it'll be close
between Trump and Biden to adopt it as well.